el canal Osama still come loreto scoffs
Academy adore her father pollute on a to
tell us very sleek Spanx please ignore
miss Clinton scoped till alfred nobel's
minute I do run go on so no Academy
instead the secretary or may may have
run know-it-all professor to realism
some a wood for Andy please committee
and fair economy preset oh professor
York of sense on sommelier the root of
committee welcome to the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences it is now time to
announce the various tricks bank prize
in economic sciences in memory of Alfred
Nobel the price is funded by donations
from the central bank of Sweden and has
been awarded since 1969 I am John Hanson
secretary-general of the Academy and
with me on the podium or two members of
the prize committee its chairman
professor to ellingson and professor
York absense on who is also a member of
the committee I will start by reading
the announcement we will hear
presentations from my colleagues on the
panel we hope to have a lower it with us
on the phone line and of course we look
forward to your questions in English or
in Swedish ready or its priests and
laron consumption is to chose not this
year's price is about consumption great
and small ganglia Vuitton's cops academy
not be salute that you tell us various
tricks banks priests the economic Nathan
Scott till alfred nobel's mean for all
sugar hundra Fenton till angus deeton
fir'aun's analyst of consumption fat the
doom of elf at the royal swedish academy
of sciences has today decided toward the
various riksbank prize in economic
sciences
in memory of Alfred Nobel to angus
deeton for his analysis of consumption
poverty and welfare we were hoping to
display the citation on the screen but
apparently something is wrong with the
technique here so I think I'll read the
citation again the price goes to angus
deeton for his analysis of consumption
poverty and welfare professor Deaton is
from Scotland originally but is now
working since many years at Princeton
University in New Jersey in the United
States let's see if we can get him on
the screen yes here we have professor
Deaton on your screen and with that I
think I'll hand over the word to the
chairman of the prize committee
professor to Ray ellingson who will make
some introductory remarks about this
year's prize to the please thank you
science often faces the question can we
understand large scale patterns without
detailed information about small scale
processes in economic science we used to
hope that the answer was yes we can
historically we lacked data about
choices at the level of the individual
and the household in order to make sense
of our macro level data we therefore
conducted our analysis on the
presumption that all people are
essentially alike and face the same kind
of constraints for example poor
households were presumed to behave in
roughly the same way as rich households
only with less money at their disposal
today in large part due to the work of
Angus Deaton and his collaborators we
not only understand the limitation of
that approach we also have the data and
the skills that are required to do
better my colleague jakub svensson will
now offer a brief introduction to angus
deeton most important contributions
please on thank you very much so let's
see if this works yes so the study of
consumption has been and continues to be
at the center of the economic research
and there are several reasons for that
first consumption is an essential
determinant of human welfare for some
actually it might be the most crucial
determinant second consumption data or
expenditure data forms the basis for
measuring poverty in many developing
countries a third aggregate consumption
forms the largest component of a great
demand in many countries and thus
account so much of the time variation in
economic activity over the business
cycle and forth the flipside of
consumption is savings so once you had
to turn it income and determined
consumption you also have determined
savings and through the supply of
capital then you have influenced
long-run investments but consumption is
a complex understanding and measuring
consumption is an anchor complex and
ever however thanks to the work of Angus
Deaton which they have a much deeper
understanding on the number of core
issues related to consumption so Angus
Deaton receives this year's prize in
economic sciences for three related
achievements first his work on so-called
demand systems
second for his work linking consumption
and income at aggregate as well as at
the individual level and finally for his
work on measuring and understanding
living standards and poverty in
developing countries and I thought I'll
take a few moments then to go through
these three core contributions starting
with demand system and let's start with
an example let's think of a government
that plans to increase the vatm food
presumably or hopefully we were like
that government than to find out which
social groups will gain and which social
group will lose and how large or the
gains and our Lord's are the losses but
in order to determine that we need to
determine how consumption of various
goods and services change in response to
the reform and in order to determine
that we need to know how prices and
incomes and changes in prices and
incomes affects individuals consumption
decisions that is we need to estimate a
so-called demand system research on the
bus system as a long history in
economics but it was not until nineteen
eighteen and the introduction of the
so-called almost ideal demand system by
Angus Deaton and co-author that we had
the first system that manages to
accurately capture real world demand
patterns so this system and the later
improvements to it are nowadays standard
tool to study the effects of economic
policy but also is that an important
tool in research to understand for
instance how to compare living standards
across countries or within countries
over time second core contribution deals
with the links between consumption and
income and let's start with let's start
with again with an example think about
fiscal policy Oh stabilization policy
then traditionally our focus has been on
aggregate variables however
the process through which these a great
variables is determined actually takes
place at the individual level and
failure to take that into account and
estimate models at the aggregate level
can actually real the wrong results this
in essence is the so-called Deaton
paradox but beat dito not only uncovered
a paradox he also pointed towards a
solution to that paradox and as the
picture here illustrated the key to
understanding this paradox is to look
closer at the process of average or a
great income because it is in fact so
that incomes of individuals fluctuates
in a very different way than average
income at some given time period some
individuals get a positive income show
some other individuals get a negative
income shock and when you look at the
average will you a great these numbers
both most of these changes averages away
so the solution or resolving the d-10
paradox is to study consumption at the
individual level relationship between
consumption and income at the individual
level and thereafter a great up to the
national level and this insight that is
the importance of studying individual
behavior in order to stand important a
great outcomes has been an insight that
has had long and lasting influence in
modern economic macroeconomics final
contribution deals with measuring living
standards and poverty in developing
countries and again let me take you let
me give you an example so in principle
it's an easy task to measure poverty in
a low-income country you start by
determining a poverty line and then you
simply count the number or the share of
individuals with either an income level
or a consumption level below that
poverty line in practice however it is a
difficult problem so while we might have
good expenditure data on
disposal we typically do not know the
prices and the quality of the goods that
this household have consumed so in work
that have had a large impact on actual
policy or actual poverty measurement in
many developing countries Deaton showed
a way to overcome this problem in other
work has focused more on the
understanding world poverty and among
other things he has showed how to
account for the increase of nearly a
half a billion poor as reported in one
of the World Bank's latest update and
more generally detain us show that our
measure of of world poverty a given
point in time is very sensitive to the
assumption made to come up with these
with these numbers finally let me say a
few words about the overall themes and
impact as I as I hopefully have shown
details research spans many different
aspects of consumption but there are
also a number of common denominators one
is his desire to bridge theory and data
a second as the picture tries to
illustrate this desire to reach
individual behavior and a great outcomes
that is in order to understand important
a great outcomes we need to look closer
and understand individual behavior and
these insights have had a large
influence on microeconomics
macroeconomics and maybe in particular
development economics his research has
also had a large influence on practical
policy making finally a few words about
the laureate himself done angus deeton
was born in 1945 he still 69 years old
in Edinburgh UK is an American and
British citizen he received his PhD in
1974 74 from University of Cambridge and
he has since 1983 being a professor of
economics and international affairs at
princeton univ
thank you very much thank you your copy
let's see if we can have professor
Deaton with us on the phone hello
professor Dayton thing no hello can you
hear me yes good morning professor
Dayton this is Jordan Hansen at the
academy of sciences in Stockholm again
thank you I've been low thank you and
your coloring great we are now in the
midst of a press conference here in the
session whole of the Academy and I'm
sure the journalists would like to ask
you some questions are you ready for
them I'll try my back thank you very
good so let's see I think Christina
Lagerstrom from Swedish television think
thank you congratulations to the price
mr. Deaton thank you very much I wonder
you are rewarded among other things for
your work on gender discrimination
within the family in developing
countries how would you say that your
work could could address this problem
and help um I like a lot of my work I'm
mostly concerned with trying to measure
the expense of these thing and I was
mostly concerned with looking at whether
little boys and little girls are treated
differently and we suddenly find a
little bit of that but I'm not sure that
this measurement really established
exactly what was going on and I think
more direct measures are published other
thank you okay more questions for
professor Deaton yes question over there
couldn't we have a microphone yes hello
mr. Deaton and congratulations my name
is Andrew Nathan from Swedish newspaper
svenska dog loaded and I would like to
hear your ideas of the current
refugee crisis migrant crisis happening
after all you have studied poverty and
yeah so I would like to see from your
point of view how do you see what is
happening at the moment well I mean I
think that what is happening has its
roots in long distance history and that
the what we're seeing now in some sense
is the result of you know hundreds of
years of unequal development in the rich
world which has left a lot of the world
behind and those people who can walk
behind would like a better lives than
those putting enormous pressure on the
board boundaries within the / world of
the rich world again I'm not sure that
understanding that leads to the solution
for the very difficult problems that are
facing Europe right now and then I know
this is a this is a big question but
from your point of view do you see
anything that could solve the situation
well I think poverty reduction in poor
countries will solve the problem but
it's not going to solve a problem for a
very long time and in the short run sort
of stabilizing political bullet
politically volatile situations that war
zones really would help thank you more
question for professor Deaton guests
over there the gentleman over there
you'll get a microphone in a second my
name is you wanna shake her be something
in the newspaper in Sweden dong sneaker
prophesied Easton congratulations I
would like to ask you about the extreme
poverty that has been decreasing quite a
lot in the recent decades do you foresee
a continuation of that development or do
you think there are any thresholds that
are hindering it in the future yes i do
first be discreet i think we
remarkable be people like 20 or 30 years
and I do expect that continue but like
all forecasts they're extremely
dangerous really bad thing it happened
but i would actually I I don't want to
sound like a blind optimistic because
it's also true that there are enormous
numbers of people in the world the World
Bank has just come by with recent
estimates about 700 million people who
live in something posted esthetician
there's also tremendous health problem
among adults and children in India where
again there's been a lot of progress
something like half of the children are
still way way of their nourish am and so
while i buy things to get better you
have to keep remembering that were not
out of the woods here and for many many
people in the world things are very bad
indeed do we have any more questions for
professor Deaton yes right there lady in
red congratulations mr. detail i'm sofia
alexis song i'm from a green post here
it's eddie for your analysis of
consumption poverty and Welfare I like
you to explain a little bit in the
current consuming society should we
consume more to expand the call me or
should people save a little bit or
consume according to what they income is
can you comment on this question thank
you thank you um I don't think it this
is my role in in spite of this very
distinguished by to tell people what
they should be doing and whether they
should be staging or very consuming more
I am NOT someone who believe that the
increase in consumption has
really worthless I don't think it's a
rat race I think a lot of what we have
now I things that make our life our
lives very much better and i think the
ball of my head is going to stop back
but to stop that inflicting damage on
other people around the world and for
instance it's clear that there are huge
unsolved problem associated with with
climate change for example and i think
the current upward trends in inequality
are very worrying as many contacts to
run the world so I don't have a simple
answer to that but my general messages
you know my measurement and show that
things are getting better but there's a
lot of work though and the world is not
a good fight is getting better thank you
thank you please yes the prize in
economic sciences was established
already 1969 your work is about poverty
and welfare why do you think that you
are awarded now at this point your your
field well I only just find out why this
morning I mean you have to read this
vacation I'm so I'm absolutely delighted
and I think that someone you know who's
concerned with the poor of the world
with how people behave and what makes
them what makes them you know gives them
a good life I'm so delighted not just
for myself but this sort of work is
being recognized so that's a wonderful
thing that's a question you can ask also
to the committee members here later on
during the press conference or the more
questions from press deaton yes please
over here lady over there you get the
microphone congratulations mr. Deaton
ammonium solution for people's daily and
I think your analysis is based on a lot
of data so i would like to ask how did
you collect all the data and how
many countries have you covered thank
you oh gosh look that's the really
difficult question I've I mean I
collected a little data myself
throughout my career but I mostly relied
on data to be collected by other people
particularly data by specific laws
around the world for the sort of great
unsung heroes of our understanding of
economics is magnificent work that's
been done by specific offices especially
statistical office is in poor countries
to labor under very difficult
circumstances in many cases my own work
has focused on many many countries at
various time I found a lot of work in
the United States I did a lot of work in
prison I spent a lot of my career
working on India m and estimate lesser
extent in South Africa but for instance
with my good friends as the Gallup
Organization i recently done a lot of
work looking all around the world and
they have some wonderful theta in
looking at well-being all around the
planet thank you the gentleman over
there yes professor my name is Tobias I
work for Swedish news it is it here in
Sweden ah this might be a little bit off
topic but i just want to hear from you
your first reaction when you got it got
a call from stockholm and who you told
the greatness gosh i was pretty sleepy
it felt like the better so i was just
delighted obviously like many many
economists I knew this was a possibility
but in any given year the odds are very
very small and I was surprised and
delighted and it was wonderful to hear
the voices of my friend on the committee
it is much thank you are there more
questions for professor Deaton if not I
think that was the last question for you
so thank you very much professor Dayton
for being
with us on the phone today and
congratulations again and welcome to
stockholm in december i look forward to
a very much and thank you all thank you
but I so now let's move on to questions
to the panel are there any questions to
the panel right can you knock sourcing
again I'd like to ask I don't know
whether we you come but it's a how do
you decide or what is an ideal demanding
system would like you you want to take
that very briefly and an ideal demand
system is a system that manages to pick
up a lot of variation in the data on
demand sistant can help you understand
why people are choosing what you're
choosing as functions of the prices and
incomes that may be many other things
like demographic factors I think that's
the core of a good demand system there
are other things that we as economies
would like from a demand system but in
essence in the end we want to have a
system like managed to explain choices
people are making more questions
if we have provided all the information
you need it and satisfied your curiosity
then we close this press conference I
know that several of you have requested
interviews with price committee members
and they will commence immediately
afterwards thank you very much for
attending thanks so much bye-bye
you
professor York absense on your the
member of the economic sciences price
committing please tell us a bit more
about this year's prize what kind of
research shall be awarded so generally
the research is a common denominator is
research on consumption and more
specifically Dita's contributions or
divided up to three core components one
has to deal with deals with so-called
demand system trying to understand what
consumption people consumption choices
people make such function of prices of
these goods and their income and various
other potential important factors the
other important contribution deals with
more thinking about aggregate
relationship between a grid consumption
and a great the income and where he has
shown that in order to understand these
patterns in the data in a better way we
need to start from the individual and
start to understand individual behavior
to then a great up to the to the
National Lab and finally has done a very
important work on measuring and
understanding living standards and
poverty in developing countries and
among his many contributions or
developing tools to measure poverty in
cases where we don't have very good
price and quality data on the goods that
people are consumed when they do is most
important research
yeah I had the research on demand system
was done in the late 1970s and much of
his work in a great relationship between
income and consumption was done in the
latter part of the 1980s and from 90s
forward he has done a lot of work on
developing the economics and he's still
active research is still a very active
researcher very much so more findings to
look forward to I probably fix it okay
as the politics just anything to learn
from this kind of research yeah I think
you ought to as this policy makers you
have a lot to learn from this research I
think all three of his core
contributions have a direct link to
policies or demand system is a tool you
can do to evaluate different types of
economic policy proposals like changes
in taxes there's work on an aggregate
income and consumption you know it's an
important issue when it comes to
stabilization pole is in to understand
the correct type of access you take is
inside of understanding individual
behavior is virtually important find
this work on poverty had a large impact
how you actually go about you measure
poverty in many developing countries
it's the press about consumption as the
ordinary consumer and thing to learn
about this like you and me I think we do
first of all what I think we do because
we care about
the welfare of poor individuals of poor
households in developing countries and
in order to do anything about that we
need to measure see how many they are
and where they live and what you can do
about it but of course also when we
think about government's changing
various economic policies I think it's
important for us to know how it will
affect our welfare was it hard to make
the decision this year this is only my
second year in the committee so I don't
have so much to compare with but it's
it's a long process so but I think we're
in the end we were very much in
agreement that this was a very good
choice how did Loras react when he heard
the news yeah I know him a little bit I
thought he was in a bit of a state of
shock he is usually a very elegant and
speaker at the answers in long sentences
but the replies we got were very short
but I think he was very very happy
extreme poverty has decreased in the
world today can Angus Vita little
research help us to have the decrease to
continue further on yeah i think the
word i think primarily a angers work on
unproven it is how you measure it in the
best possible way and I think measuring
poverty well is important you be ordered
in order to evaluate what policies works
and what do not and here he has made a
huge impact I think there's if you look
at the data there's nothing that tells
us that this reduction in absolute
poverty will not continue but of course
we we never know and finally has the
Lord written some kind of book for the
big audience that we can read if are
interesting in this topic yes just a
year or two ago he came out with a book
called The Great Escape if I remember
correctly which talks a little bit about
his own life but also more generally
about parties we absorb in the date
long wrong development in income and
poverty and welfare that I think is a
very good book to me thank you very much
thank you very much